dites-moi ce que vous ne croyez pas au
destin ou au moindre mal en quoi croyez-vous
qu'est-ce qu'un sorceleur cheveux blancs
devenir solitaire se sentir très très effrayant esquiver des
épées je sais qui vous êtes un sorceleur est un
mutant et leur métier en particulier est
monstre le boucher de Barbican,
vous êtes presque universellement détesté par
toutes les espèces du consulat, il est
peu probable que vous ayez une
personnalité joyeuse, mais Geralt lui-même, malgré
l'extérieur pierreux, est en fait assez
bon, ils sont très capables de faire de mauvaises
choses.
Geralt n'est pas  simplement un chevalier blanc
il est simplement un dur chasseur de monstres il est
un incroyable mélange des deux les
rumeurs sur les sorcières sur le fait qu'elles n'ont pas
d'émotions vous ne faites pas de prisonniers
alors ici et cela se perpétue par eux
parfois comme des monstres
parfois il y a de l'argent rarement patron
[Musique]
lors de leur création, ils subissent des
épreuves alchimiques qui sont une combinaison
d'élixirs et de magie qui ont
des effets très agressifs sur leur corps, cela
leur permet de prendre divers po  tions
ces potions les améliorent de diverses
et différentes manières les signes que les sorcières
jettent ce sont de la magie basique mais très très
efficace vous voyez souvent passer cet humour très sec
qui est l'un des
aspects les plus charmants de fille vous sentez la
mort et le destin c'est sur  vous savez
que le destin est l'un des thèmes majeurs
qui est une force qui le
contrôle et en effet le monde qui l'entoure
gerelds aggrave le destin il n'y
croit pas
mais il s'avère qu'il y a peut-être un peu
plus que le plus grand de la fille
la force est sa capacité à toujours aimer
malgré sa retraite incroyablement
Harshman malgré ce qu'il dit, il
croit toujours en la bonté des gens et
vous couplez cela avec
une vitesse d'agilité
et une endurance incroyables, alors vous avez un
personnage intéressant
[Musique]
[Musique  ]
voici votre première leçon car dans la vie il est
impossible d'être toujours parfaitement préparé
pour la bataille
gardez votre épée près et continuez à bouger
il y a quelque chose de spécial à propos  mais cette
fille, elle est très fidèle aux gens
qu'elle aime, elle en a construit un cœur,
mais n'a tout simplement pas eu d'expérience dans
le monde réel, tout ce qu'elle sait, c'est une
vie protégée en tant que princesse et ce
réseau très sécurisé de personnes qui s'occupent
d'elle  elle ne t'a pas tiré dessus Cass,
elle est très implacable, très têtue et
elle est aussi très naïve, je pense qu'elle
veut juste s'assurer qu'elle ne se retrouve pas
piégée dans cette boîte.
une princesse et elle veut en quelque sorte
se libérer de cela, mais elle est soudainement
abandonnée de manière très brutale Hitler
après qu'elle soit devenue quelque chose de très
effrayant, c'est le numéro de savoir quand il est temps
d'arrêter de bouger,
elle perd tous ceux qu'elle connaît en
une nuit
un  l'énorme thème de The Witcher est la perte
de la famille dans la recherche de la famille si
ce sont les derniers mots que sa
grand-mère lui a dit, cela signifie
beaucoup et je pense que c'est ce qui la
maintient déterminée à continuer  e sur c'est tout ce
qu'il lui reste pour s'accrocher ça compte
beaucoup pour elle mais elle ne
sait pas encore trop ce que ça veut dire être une princesse
n'a plus d'importance
elle ne sait juste pas par où commencer
sois prudente enfant
[  Musique]
cet endroit n'est pas sûr si vous êtes seul
et c'est comme tous les autres endroits où
vous